[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Roger Penrose Susan Sontag and Wilson
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to our evening discussion of
image and meaning I'm Alan Lightman of
MIT and it is my pleasure and privileged
to be the host of tonight's session in
the history of modern science a central
measure of progress has been the degree
to which knowledge can be expressed in
numbers and equations and concepts a
ball takes 1.3 seconds to fall a
distance of 30 feet the electrical force
between two electrons varies as the
square of the distance between them the
energy of a closed system is always the
same to represent a concept or a result
in this form has usually been considered
the most precise form of understanding
nature but knowledge can also be
presented and misrepresented in pictures
and images our minds and imaginations
react to these representations in a
different way than to numbers and
equations and here we must remember that
we can objectify and distill all that we
want but meaning and understanding must
ultimately be assigned by the human mind
image and meaning is really a matter of
human perception we are sitting here
tonight in one of the world's temples of
science and technology dedicated to the
study of physical phenomena atoms and
molecules DNA computers galaxies but of
all the wonderful mysteries of nature
nothing is more mysterious
are profound than the human mind somehow
we are aware of ourselves and our
relationship to the outside world
somehow we think somehow we assign
meaning to the billions of sensory
inputs constantly flooding our brains
somehow we create new ideas more
specifically in the context of our
gathering tonight in our conference
topic of image and meaning I want to
raise the following four questions what
role do images and visualization
play in the creative process how do
images change the way that we think of
ourselves
how do images help scientists in the
research beyond the help provided by
numerical data and finally in what ways
do scientists communicate their work and
what ways do images helped scientists
communicate their work work to
non-scientists to stimulate our thought
tonight about these and related
questions we have with us three of the
most interesting minds of our time Roger
Penrose Susan Sontag and Edward o Wilson
Roger Penrose is a mathematician and
physicist at Oxford in the 1960s
Penrose proved very general conditions
under which the universe had to have
originated in a Big Bang Penrose often
uses pictures and diagrams in his work
he is renowned for his discovery of
Penrose tiles which are two geometric
shapes that can completely cover an
infinite plane without ever repeating a
pattern in his book the emperor's new
mind
penrose broaden his interests to
consider the nature of thinking and
human consciousness among his many
awards
Penrose has won the Wolf Prize which he
shared with Stephen Hawking in 1988 and
I learned tonight that a collection of
Rogers drawings will be shown in the
Ruskin School of Fine Arts at Oxford
Susan Sontag is one of the great
literary and cultural voices of America
in both fiction and nonfiction she
explores topics ranging from the
American consciousness and identity to
the cultural and literary meaning of
illness to to the different complexions
of the narrative voice in the modern
novel her nonfiction includes such books
as against interpretation in other
essays illness is metaphor and under the
sign of Saturn and her novels include
the benefactor death kit the volcano
lover and most recently in America
sonntag is a winner of the National Book
Award in the National Book Critics
Circle Award and just recently she has
won the prestigious Jerusalem
International Book Award Edward o Wilson
is an evolutionary biologist and
zoologist at Harvard
Wilson is equally famous for his
decades-long detailed study of the tiny
ant and his broad analyses and theories
about the biological principles that
govern social behavior and organization
in all kinds of animals including us
some of Wilson's many books include the
ants on human nature and sociobiology
sociobiology one of his most recent
books Concilium concerns commonalities
between
all forms of human knowledge Wilson
among his other awards is twice won the
Pulitzer Prize and I learned from him
tonight
that he is at work on another book on
what of all subjects but aunts 800 pages
including over 5,000 of his own drawings
of ants I want to begin by giving a
brief summary of the format for the
evening we will start with a series of
six images which you will all see here
on the screen and I hope that our
panelists can see here or here or by
straining your neck and looking
backwards these are images which have
not been shown before to our guests each
of our guests will then speak for ten
minutes during which he or she something
happening okay all right let me know
when something happens each of our
guests will then speak for about ten
minutes in which he or she can either
give a spontaneous reaction to the
images or address the four questions
that I brought up earlier or speak on
any topic that is relevant
to our conference then we'll have about
20 minutes of dialogue between the three
of them and which they can talk to each
other I may in insert a question or two
and after that I'll open the floor for
questions and comments for another half
hour
so are you ready to have some fun good
well let's begin with the images
Roger can we start with you okay well
let me comment first on your images here
I mean the first one presumably is the
atomic bomb explosion which I take to
represent the issue of science and the
responsibility that one has in
developing in this case nuclear energy I
certainly one of those people who
believes that you can't really I mean
some people think that science okay
that's a pure activity you can do it you
don't have to worry about the social
consequences I mean there's something in
me which believes that too that science
is something that should be done for its
own sake but on the other hand it does
seem to me that the scientists after all
are the people who have the best
knowledge of what their discoveries are
likely to do and so therefore they do
have a responsibility to at least pay
attention to these issues so I certainly
one of these people who believes that
that you can't really separate the pure
science from what potential applications
it might have and whether they be used
for benefit or otherwise of course
scientists are not always very accurate
in their predictions in this way and I
think there's some famous quote from
Rutherford who thought that nuclear
energy would never be useful for
anything so you can't always believe
what they say but on the other hand they
are in a better position than other
people so responsibilities there I take
the second image to be representative
well it certainly is the earth rising
from the moon and it does represent a
fantastic achievement a technological
achievement not so much a scientific
achievement although that there is of
course that goes back back to Newton one
appreciates that space travel was
potentially possible but it's really a
technology technological achievement
which required a great deal of money and
so on and I feel a great thrill in this
I mean I was I was one of these people
who stayed up all night when the first
moon landings came out and so on I think
it's a great thing that people can do
this because they're not doing it now
but
so maybe they'll go to Mars one day and
so I'm like that kind of thing I think
it's great but it is expensive of course
and one has to worry about how these
things affect other research which might
be going on yeah we have Crick and
Watson and of course this was a
fantastic thing they did to discover the
structure of DNA and it did set off a
tremendous revolution in in in biology
it probably represents a number of other
things because in a sense I seem to
remember from reading Watson's book or
somewhere that they they argued how how
ignorant they were of some of these
things at the time they were doing it
and maybe it's a case for not knowing
too much because if you don't know too
much about what other people are doing
you can bring it bring a new perspective
on the subject and maybe that's in this
illustration of that it certainly was a
wonderful scientific achievement there's
no question about that
and we were going to see further
developments from that and in the genome
project and so on and then again one has
these issues of social consequences
which maybe all come up again in one of
the other later images the development
from here
well that's supposed to be a great
showing how human beings are somehow the
pinnacle of evolution
it also shows because there are cartoons
which show these things going opposite
directions and so on and they start
coming back down again it's it's a
wonderful image it may not be it also
reflects somehow that human beings are
part of mammal animal life as a whole
and that there isn't a dividing line
between the humans and and other animals
which I believe very strongly so that
when one talks about things like the
human mind one is really talking about
mind and mind is not just human mind one
has to think about animals it's
something that I worried about with all
this great business with foot-and-mouth
in in the UK and with all this
tremendous slaughter of
of cattle and so on and nobody ever
mentioned that somehow there were any
rights for the animals and when it was
all to do with what was economically the
best thing and so on and so forth
and I didn't hear a single person
certainly another politician mentioned
that should we think whether one can
infinite number of animals is equivalent
to one human or something is that a fair
equation seem to me it goes against the
grain very much with me yeah it looks
like well a baby a fetus or maybe a
collie the baby at this stage in the
womb which does raise certain issues of
the relation of science to moral issues
more or less when does life begin and so
on well I think it's a difficult
question I certainly don't believe that
that one should regard few week old
fetus as having I mean think that there
are issues we don't know yet and this
probably it relates to perhaps the next
image to which is the question of a
brain and what's going on in the brain
and here we have imaging of there's
presumably somebody thinking about
various things and where is it to be
pinpointed in the brain because that
doesn't tell us a great deal about what
it is to have an awareness of something
so although it's a tremendous
achievement in science to to find out
what goes on we're in different parts of
the brain does it really tell us what it
is that's going on when somebody is
aware of something of consciousness so I
think there's a great deal that science
is going to have to do before we answer
this question I'm certainly one of these
people I've written about these things
and get them to lots of trouble with
people sometimes but my general view is
that we simply don't know yet what's
really going on even in a serious way
we're going to have to know more physics
than we do at the moment before we could
know what could be going on even to
evoke consciousness so the issue of
consciousness then relates to the
central the red one in the middle there
and it's a question of when does a fetus
actually become a person in the sense
being conscious my guess it is fairly
early but I don't think it's a matter of
a few weeks I think you have to have a
significant looking thing but that's a
guess the question is we really have to
know these things so I would think a
baby in the womb of the coracoid a baby
then certainly does have some kind of
consciousness
I would guess this from experiences that
I've had recently because my wife is I
have a one-year-old child now and I
remember the baby was sensitive to to
music already I would say about a month
before it was born so I think there are
things going on there at that late stage
but these are our questions which at the
moment is we have no hand long and we're
going to have to understand a lot more
about what consciousness is about before
we can really have a handle on these
issues of of the moral questions in
relation to two unborn children and so
on well I see how many more minutes do I
have if any three okay let me make a few
comments about some of the things I've
been seeing in the conference up to this
point I must say I've found it quite
fascinating and I do think that there
are tremendous developments a lot of
these have to do with computers and
others have to do with ways in which
people can explore very small objects
and so on and very distant objects and
so on I did find the the things about
the film is the last night very moving
in some ways and very impressive but
there are moral issues which come up
there and I think one has to face up to
these things one of these things I think
that was today maybe about the question
of doctoring photographs and so on I did
wonder whether there ought to be some
sort of a law which says that you can't
use a photograph and doctorate without
saying that you've done and what you've
done
so it seems to me using a photograph is
fine but if it has been changed in some
way that is illegal
unless you actually say the change has
been made and it seems to me I would
very much support some sort of law that
it was just something that occurred to
me while I was seeing these things let
me make one slightly trivial point
frivolous I was going to say points not
frivolous actually but one thing also I
was feeling when I wasn't noticing
people with giving their talks here was
that there's some respects in which the
developments in technology are not
really in advance and one of these is
one of my little bug bears I'm afraid
I've noticed that when I sit at the back
of the room and somebody points at
something with this wonderful laser
pointer I simply can't see a thing he
says this thing over here what and maybe
by the time you know five M if he's held
it on the same point for five minutes
maybe I would see it but a good old
stick you know we used to have pointing
at something yeah that's fine
so these are it just seems to me that
sometimes technology just by itself is
not necessarily advanced other times it
is one can't tell but it's one certainly
has to take on what the advantages are
but not just because it's new I don't
think one should necessarily be driven
in that direction were there any other
points I should make yes I guess I
should make this point that I mean
visual images I don't regard to
something fundamentally different from
other means of communication it's just
that it's it's a way in which you can
very understanding often very rapidly
which depends on the subject of course
but sometimes you can do this sometimes
words you need a lot more of them
sometimes the image is pretty
incomprehensible you need to describe it
but it is a very powerful thing and I
think with technology that's been coming
up it's something which will increase in
its in its importance and I like that
because as technology develops there is
a slightly negative element which
perhaps I would like to bring up which
is the ease of communication isn't
always a positive thing because it does
mean that fashionable ideas spread the
globe almost instantaneously whereas in
the good old days here's going to go
back to some things which I like about
the good old days you had these pockets
of people working away at different
things and there was a kind of people
didn't have to
do what everybody else was doing whereas
with the internet internet is fine and
it's great that people in in saying in
developing countries can can see what's
going on in other countries and so on
without having to buy the journals and
things like that okay and International
Cooperation so on is great but on the
other hand there is a downside which
means that fashionable ideas sometimes
have much greater hole I think in modern
science than they did before
communication was so easy so I think
that's something that one has to face up
to and maybe see how one could move
things in in in a way which increases
the possibility of having more variety
in what they do
so I must make that comment thank you
well what's what Susan speak now well
there are very large and wonderful
subjects on the table such as the role
of visual information or visualizing and
the creative process and and and what it
means to represent knowledge visually
which I presume in the word represent is
entailed also the notion of
communicating knowledge and how
visualizing and visual representation
aids in the pedagogic process for
instance those are those are very
important issues but I think I will wait
for a moment and just address these
fascinating images I guess the first
thing I would say is that what strikes
me about these images and roger penrose
and wave responded to what I think is at
the heart of this particular display of
six images is he took them as
representative he was invited we're all
invited to respond to them but he but to
say that their representative is not the
only way of responding to them but what
he
did was to say well that image of the
atom bomb are the hydrogen bomb what it
reminds us of the ethical issues in
certain kinds of scientific and
technological work the image of of the
earth seen from the moon reminds us or
suggests questions about space travel
Crick and Watson let's say remind us of
of the glories of scientific achievement
etc etc each of them are taken as
representative of a thought a problem a
task a confluence I I'm rather
suspicious of this way of thinking about
images I think it's it's more and more
foisted on us by our televisual culture
but I think it's actually a rather
shallow approach to thinking about
images I'm not saying you are shallow
I'm saying that to this display
encourages please miss please understand
me this display precisely encourages
that way of looking at images I'm not
I'm not talking about the response
because I think it's a it's a very
normal response
but you put images which are in fact
famous images so please bear with me
these are famous images these are
celebrity images these are images chosen
for the fact that even I a scientific
illiterate know what all of those images
are I recognize them and very few people
in this in this space I was ignorant of
science as I am but I recognize all six
of these images I know exactly what what
is being shown there now so they are
chosen precisely because they're
representative precisely because they
are as it were celebrity images or let
me put it even more bluntly they are the
visual equivalent of sound bytes I think
this is not a very
good good way into the question of
images I think it it encourages thinking
about images in a way that's that takes
us away from real knowledge I mean there
is after all I think an argument for
saying a case rather to be made up to
the argument that we really don't
understand very much through images
images are at best only aids and they
always are in a particular context the
context of these images is that we're
having a conversation and this is a way
of introducing the conversation but my
first reaction was oh those famous
images and as Alan Lightman told you we
weren't told what the images were going
to be and they were kind of surprised
and when they came up I thought oh [ __ ]
those images I know those images I
thought they were going to be more
interesting more weird the only one that
seems genuinely weird is the so called
fetus which could be maybe I'm too much
of a movie goer the star child in 2001
I'm not a hundred percent convinced of
all though if Alan tells me it is that
it's a real fetus but anyway Stanley
Kubrick and his art director Douglas
Trumbull they made an imitation of that
if those of you know that great movie of
Stanley Kubrick it ends with with indeed
that version of that image so we are
we're not only in an era of celebrity
and an era of televisual reality which
is so compelling for people we're in an
era of celebrity images in which certain
images then are taken as representatives
they trigger responses where we say okay
this is a subject of debate and
everything that roger penrose said about
how we could think about these problems
their real problems what I'm questioning
is more and more a kind of
short-circuiting of the long laborious
process that is conducted in words and
an argument as if really we understand I
think what's suggested is that we
understand more from images that we than
we really do I mean what my own view is
except again thinking of these five
thousand images of ants in 800 pages of
text I'm sure these are incredibly
informative but they are in a context I
think images obviously always appear in
a context and the way we think about
images is contextually driven so I
suppose the first thing I want to say as
perverse as it may seem is that the
context of these images is this
discussion and it's completely
adventitious it's in a way completely
false
in fact these images have nothing to do
with each other and this use of images
I think tends images in series famous
images celebrity images and how many
context magazines books television etc
are we invited to recognize the image in
fact if you go to a movie theater now
you know and after you start munching on
the popcorn and before the ads and the
trailers start you may get a lot of
images and then you're invited to
recognize what movie this is from or
what actor is represented so I'm I'm a
little worried about the the extent to
which we take images as telling us very
much my feeling is more we remember
through images but we understand through
words and I'm not sure how much we
understand outside of context supplied
by pre-existent assumptions by argument
that can be expressed in words I don't
think the images are telling us really
anything at all they are very often form
of entertainment now they are
entertaining and even more than that
they give pleasure images give pleasure
they don't only give information they
give pleasure there's also another thing
to be said obviously it's so obvious
that it's that you feel you don't have
to say it and yet I think it is we're
saying these are all photographs and
obviously that is not the own
the form of image making and not far
from the only form of image making which
is instructive or useful I should
imagine in scientific work so I'm not
I'm not so sure what images are standing
for except as this kind of shorthand or
what I call the you know the visual
soundbite yes it's true and if it's a
famous image will have some associations
with it and will have associations about
particular problems but I don't think we
know very much and I don't think except
insofar as any image can be an object of
reverie and incitement to dream to
fantasize that that the image is telling
us anything at all and also the image
images identify things that we think we
should be thinking about I've been I've
been thinking a lot about the use of
photography in alerting us to
catastrophe and disaster and and giving
us a sense of war and what goes on in
war and there's of course a very long
history of this that goes back in
photography to let's say the Crimean War
which is the first war that had any real
coverage in in abide by photography and
what's interesting is what Wars we know
about through photography and what Wars
we're much less aware of because we
don't have photographic evidence of them
photographic witness of them so
photographic knowledge identifies
defines makes memorable and it also
excludes lots of other things that we
should it not only points us to things
we should be thinking about in fact the
repertoire of famous images obscures
occludes and hides I think at least as
many probably more issues than the ones
that it draws to our attention
thank you had well now answer having
crawled into the discussion I would like
to use them to first show the use at
least in science of images in the
context of creative work and and
basically search well it's true that I
am just completing the monograph of
about six hundred and twenty five
species of ants some three hundred and
thirty five of them are new to science
and they constitute about twenty percent
of all the known answer issues or the
Western Hemisphere
why am i doing that well let me explain
and then I I have personally drawn the
aspects of their Anatomy appearance and
diagnostic traits with over 5,000
drawing this is part of the process of
addressing a group of organisms that you
love that you really care about and are
intellectually excited about that it's
much more than that as you go into a
monograph of this kind you are living
within the subject you're looking at all
of the aspects of the traits of the
species you are drawing them yourself
you're getting that visual feedback and
in biology especially we are focused on
and we are driven by images so we learn
in detail when it comes it goes deep
into our consciousness and then a part
of this is collecting these creatures in
the field of getting the sense of where
they live entering the actual habitats
and looking at their ecology and their
behavior and learn
and more and this then helps us
illustrate what I perceive as the two
strategies of doing research in biology
first is whether it's called two types
of biologists to be a stereotypical
about it the first type addresses the
problem and knows that for every problem
in biology there is an organism ideally
suited to its solution
those bacteria for molecular genetic the
other loves the organism wishes to find
out everything he can about it and
recognizes that for every organism there
is a problem to the solution of which it
is ideally suited and that is how I
dress pants now let me go back in time
to the start of my career I've just
graduated from Harvard ph.d 1955 and I'm
in the South Pacific in New Guinea and
the islands of the South Pacific and I'm
doing this kind of study then totally
absorbed in it and the habitats in which
I live and I am thus coming intimately
to know hundreds of species of ant and
out of this I'm finding patterns the
evolutionary biologist is a typical
example of the person who goes to the
organisms and derives the solution of
problems - which is ideally suited and
often precedes the problem what it is in
the first place because we're looking
for pattern and out of this work I see
two things I see the patterns in which
the species are flowing out of the end
though in the Australian staging areas
into the into New Guinea and the outer
islands of Melanesia this flow and I see
the circumstances under which species
can spread most readily and I developed
the products for that and the second
thing that I see is that there's a very
regular relationship between the number
species on the island and the area of
the island and out of this to make a
long story short
later I come back and I collaborate with
a young mathematical ecologist named
Robert MacArthur and we developed a
theory of Island biogeography which is
an equilibrium theory of species in
which it leads us into the concept and
the processes of immigration to
extinction and so on and connects it
with ecology now let me having said that
and and mentioning that many many
discoveries in biology are made this way
by solving problems that were never
dreamed of until you learn to live with
the organism to move to how much time
have five minutes to move to the image
of the earth rise and what do I see when
I look at that distant planet Susan what
I do first of all because I'm a bio
geographer by nature you know I first
thing automatically I do when I see
these distant photographs I say how does
the confidence look and all those maps
we've been using accurate at last we can
find out and then of course I I see it
as the astronauts see it I see it as a
distant and fragile planet and then I
say but what do we mean by fragile it's
not fragile what's fragile is the
biosphere the biosphere is that layer of
multitudinous organisms that right in
envelops it pulled home and on which our
lives depend and that biosphere
astronomical number of organisms of some
ten million species perhaps is creates
that disequilibrium it's a it is a on
atmosphere and and a temperature regime
which is out of equilibrium from what it
would be if the organisms were not there
driving it to a new point and it's
that's terribly fragile you look at that
and you try to see the biosphere you
cannot you can't even see it from a
space shuttle it's razor
thin it cannot be seen with the naked
eye edgewise and we now know from many
lines of evidence that we are disturbing
the biosphere in a way that is almost
unprecedented at least in recent
geologic history and that we are we have
become a geological force so let's go to
the progression from Australopithecus on
the left there up through the species of
Homo to Homo sapiens and Homo sapiens is
the Great destroyer and incidentally an
interesting fact is that we've estimated
that at any given time on earth there
are about a thousand trillion individual
ants alive and each ant weighs about one
millionth of a human being and that
means that there are approximately the
Baathist much biomass of answers there
are humans now this is AB this is really
abnormal for the following reason if all
humans were to disappear the everything
would come back to the equilibrium
approximately my planet would be shall
we say the biosphere would be safe for
the indefinite future but if all ants
would have disappeared the terrestrial
ecosystems would collapse it would be a
catastrophe and the whole thing would be
thrown out of kilter
[Applause]
so out of our knowledge to conclude with
something of a rhetorical note that we
have learned by all these painful
methods of the national sciences and
particularly of the studies of the
diversity of life has come the
realization that we've got to somehow
we've got to settle down before we wreck
the planet thank you
[Applause]
well let's have a let's have some
back-and-forth now yeah and if you help
why don't why don't we ask Susan if I
might have either one of us gotten close
to what she wants us to do with image I
don't want to be cranky but I just think
then that these images are just inviting
us to to to free-associate about things
that we think of when we look at I mean
I look at that image you know and I say
it's a man it's not a woman is that
interesting it's a man then
well I belong to that half of the human
race that is not likely to be
represented in a representative chart of
let's say human evolution whereas those
of you who are men probably find it
quite normal just as he stands for you
know everybody but she is kind of weird
to stand for everybody know that I bring
let's say I bring that to that image but
at the same time that I do sincerely
notice that that it is in fact a male
and not a female which could after all
just as easily illustrate that evolution
I think it is to use a word suppose used
and withdrawn at the same time it's kind
of frivolous on observation it's just an
association that I have because of my
particular ethical Sensibility etc one
I'm sure shared by many other people
needless to say but it is simply an
association we could have associations
to all of these images but I'm not sure
associations
using images as a pretext to associate
and present what we think or feel or
want to argue is a very interesting
response to images because this is
precisely a little tiny anthology it's
an anthology of famous or easily
recognizable images I think it would be
more interesting to talk about how the
vision
will has become so important for us I
think Allan Lichtman and I who are both
novelists were having a long discussion
in the middle of the afternoon about the
difference it's something that that that
preoccupies I think reflective writers
of fiction very much the difference in
writing in the first person and writing
in the third person we could also have a
conversation about the differencing
photographed images as opposed to drawn
images we could have a conversation
about the difference mean still images
and moving images etc etc those I think
would focuses on how how we think
visually how we remember visually the
way in which visualizing is essential to
the imagination and it's essential can
become essential in pedagogy and
understanding but simply to respond to
individual images I find not getting
very far to the kinds of problems that
are really I think interesting about
your objection to these particular
images I mean they in particular that
one which actually isn't a photograph of
course the one on the left at the bottom
which which a vote to response from
you're fine I mean I think that's the
sort of thing he was trying to do okay
these are images which in different ways
can evoke responses from assets and my
objection is not if my objection is that
I did think we were being invited to
reflect on the role of the visual in
helping us to understand and that the
and therefore I'd find responses to
individual images because they trigger
associations whether than my
associations of yours says he thought
that's not the point not to take us very
far what kind of images would you prefer
to have what would you put under there
well perhaps what about perhaps images
which all related to one subject look
listen we have a precedent let's talk on
very concretely Darwin
writes a book called the expression of
emotions in man and animals and he uses
a bunch of photographs which are largely
faked or staged and yet he did think
that that was a useful thing and we're
talking about 1872 I believe that book
is 1872 1873
it's an early example of somebody
thinking that visual aids in particular
protocol photographed images would be
helpful in making clear a scientific or
a descriptive or a taxonomic argument I
mean I find that very interesting that
it happened that long ago we know of
course the encyclopedia the great
encyclopedic project of the late 18th
century had images obviously they were
drawn images and not photographic images
that's anyway I think that's an
interesting thing to talk about why we
is this for instance here's here's an
obvious question and one that troubles
me is the rise of such images and the
frequency with which they occur in books
in scientific and historical works part
of a kind of democratization of
popularization of knowledge or not is
the feeling that an argument isn't
compelling to people unless it has a
visual accompaniment I mean haven't you
all been struck by the extent to which
pictures news pictures have have come
and on to the front page of newspapers
of newspapers which didn't feature them
the extent to which we now view black
and white pictures as not appropriate in
newspapers but rather that that they
should be in color etc etc why do I have
we more and more wanted to accompany
narratives political narrative
scientific narratives descriptive
accounts with
visual information I think this has a
sociological and political aspect I
don't I don't know but that's just the
kind of thing that I think about anyway
may I suggest a another connection a
wholly different direction it might help
illuminate this that has been yielded by
neurobiology it's just a tentative on
the basis of one set of experiments I
know and that is arousal of the brain
automatic arousal that you may not even
be conscious of by it's a measure of the
damping of the alpha wave which is a
good proxy for a rabid will actually
directly connected and arousal and the
experiments indicate seemed to indicate
that if we were to turn each one of
these into abstract form you know so
that they weren't recognizable images
and in our ordinary lives but make them
abstract it's very likely that the fetus
would cause the maximum arousal and to
be pretty close to a spike in how you
were automatically aroused and that
would be a figure with about 20%
redundancy and that's about the amount
of complexion you see in that fetal
diagram and that happens to be where we
settle in a great deal of abstract art
there may be a coincidence but that's
where Mondrian settled after all these
experimentation and moving away from the
literalism and it also is the amount of
complexity you see in an Asian
pictographs and English characters and
in frieze design and colophon and in
fact it's what automatically we we pay
attention to instantaneously more than
other degrees of complexity so it's just
thought in other words what does this
tell us about image and meaning I think
it probably tells us something important
it certainly tells us where what might
be a gravitational force you know in the
in the evolution of our
primitive so-called primitive art design
is it about that 20% redundancy well I
just suggested in observation I think
you raise the point which I don't think
has been at least I haven't seen it
discussed at this meeting is the
question of cartoons and that sort of
thing where you can convey some an
impression I mean not photographic but
but with much less information if you
like but nevertheless you can instantly
recognize what it is and as you say with
that image you could have done that
probably with a few lines what we call
diagnostic traits in systematics and we
use it in field guides like Peterson's
field mmm-hmm but there's another aspect
to I'd like to mention that has come out
of the subject of ethology in which is
experimentation experimental and natural
behavior study and that's a supernormal
stimulus well reminded of that by your
allusion to cartoon cartooning is as a
substantial process the exaggeration of
certain features that release that is
stimulate us in a certain way
emotionally perhaps you know through
cultural mediation sometimes
automatically so we go for the infant
for example we you exaggerate the amount
that the nose has pushed in the eyes
called large and the body of the head
there is a disproportionate large to the
infant's form and the body and and and
so on and we when we present horrific
figures either in you know horror films
or in in art meaning to dramatize the
horrors of war and so on we use
supernormal stimuli this means that in
certain stimuli a certain categories of
stimuli exaggerating the features that
you would find in a normal context would
from predators and children for what we
consider beautiful men or women
by exaggerating them you get an even
stronger response I want to do
don't you think also that it has
to do with framing I recently saw an
exhibit of war photography because I am
very right now I'm trying to write
something in which you saw the original
photograph and then you saw the
photograph has printed for instance that
very famous photograph from the Vietnam
War probably the most famous single
photograph of the naked child running
down the highway toward the camera who's
been napalmed it's actually much larger
image and I've seen the original image
and of course when it was it's shrunk so
that she's really in the center so you
can't miss her on the other hand the
larger picture is also very upsetting it
shows quite a few people including
American soldiers mostly American
soldiers standing on the side of the
road not paying any attention at all one
is talking to another one there too and
this child who must be screaming as was
their other children the picture too
they're not paying any attention but
nevertheless we we would look
differently if the picture and it would
have a different impact so it's not just
exaggeration but I think one can never
ignore framing what is excluded and and
how how information is centered in a
paper let me make a quick allusion to to
that final image and that is where our
cognitive neuroscience may be leading us
and that is that a lot of these
fundament appear to be fundamental
traits of the way the brain or the way
we respond you know to certain types of
stimuli context is and so on a lot of
that appears to be programmed and how
much it is and how much can be
culturally modified I think it's going
to be understood a great deal more as
time goes on with the aid of techniques
like the one displayed here I just
wanted to mention that in passing and
what that means is I'm not sure but it
certainly does
the ore is relevant to the general topic
of tonight which is a relation between
image and meaning I wanted to ask both
of you a question is sort of
perpendicular to Susan's comment that a
lot of images are just celebrity images
and and bring forth a canned set of
associations both of you use images in
your work I mean dad you mentioned that
you are drawing 5,000 parts of ants or
whole ants and I know Roger among all
physicists uses images to an unusual
degree geometric constructions which you
must visualize how do these images
actually help you in in your scientific
work the visualization in your case
Roger and the actual drawing by hand and
your case but I certainly I mean I find
it very useful in understanding
mathematical things I mean in my
notebooks I tend to draw lots of
pictures far more than I would actually
have calculations once it once the
problem is reduced to a calculation I
think it's almost solved because then
you know what you you can more let's
just write it down whereas it's the
conceptual ideas which are very
difficult to get to grips with without
having some kind of visual image but
often it's very difficult to have have
accurate images even people who don't
think very visually there's a there's a
famous little book by Hadamard where he
writes on how mathematicians think so on
and he describes how his ideas and he
says these blobs and things like this
and then he stands back and thinks about
it says well these blobs don't have much
information and he regards himself as
not on the visual side he's a analytical
thinker so these images are very
important for mathematical thinking I
think Keith Devlin and his talk
yesterday brought up this issue that
bringing up visual images in actual
mathematical demonstrations too for
other mathematicians
is often regarded as being kind of
inferior and you should try and get rid
of the diagram so if you do them for
your own purposes but when you want to
make an honest article you don't put
them in I think that things have moved
away from that to some degree I mean
it's sort of pendulum swings one way or
the other
and I think how images are you is quite
a bit more in very advanced mathematical
articles sometimes depends on the
subject the problem with it with these
visual images it's hard to make them
rigorous and mathematicians are very
want to make sure that arguments
actually hang together in a very strict
way and the images may be thought to be
distracting from that but I think in in
the exploratory thinking they're
absolutely right
I find the vital I don't know to what
degree other people who work in
mathematics and find this are probably
less so because I happen to be on the
bridge or side but that's just in one's
own thinking but then of course in
explaining to other people they are
extremely important it's it's quite
curious that in in mathematics teaching
you are often find that mathematics
students find the diagrams not very
helpful and I think there's a curious
reason for that and that is that there's
a kind of a selection effect but it's
very hard to have examinations which
tests the visual ability whereas the to
test the analytic and calculation
abilities that's easy and so the people
who do well on that side come through do
well in the exams and you find a lot of
them in the maths classes whereas maybe
the best ones are the one who's come
through will be able to do things on the
visual side too but you find that that
on the whole the mathematics students
which that's been my experience and not
at all visual now it's it's a curious
thing because if somebody says to me
okay we want you to do some public
lecture or something like this where
you're going to talk to people who are
who are not mathematicians
lots and lots of pictures lots of
pictures they say and that's the way you
get the ideas across to people who are
not mathematicians so it works at the
two extreme yes but I mean I find
they're very important and I think they
are extremely valuable in in getting
ideas across the people are not
mathematicians probably more so than
with mathematicians but on the other
hand I am somebody who believes that
they have anacs-- within mathematics too
so but for me they're they're absolutely
essential do you feel like you you know
your aunt's better after drawing them Oh
certainly that's you just gained that
much more familiarity and they fix it
into your mind but watching roger using
you know movements paralinguistic
signalling and then in the dinner
conversation trying to explain an
important principle of quantum mechanics
to a admittedly baffled dinner
companions the it was very effectively
using you know objects on the table to
move around and I was reminded then of
the great importance of narrative motion
and kinesthetic in involvement
kinesthetic you know we are not just
creatures of the ordinary senses we
think of other also creatures
exquisitely adapted to doing things
especially with our hands and and and
creating and producing products and so
on so this is very pleasing to us to use
our hands and to work with them and this
is extremely true of biologists who work
a whole
I'd like to so yes it's the kinesthetic
element we can do this today
incidentally yes with the accent
sometimes they in the architectural
discussion with producing actual models
you can get your hands on exactly it was
aesthetically pleasing it's it's just
much enhances learning and it certainly
enhances creativity and I'd like to ask
you a question about that I've often
wondered Stephen Hawking who I think was
your student was he not no he was well
that's what he wasn't my students let's
put it you led the way for some of his
thinking but he you know he has once
said that being unable to do
kinesthetics now he had glad he chose
theoretical physics because it's all in
the head and I wondered do you have any
sense of how not being able to right
move do these things but becoming purely
cerebral as maybe it's he's not purely
maybe I've got it wrong but how how this
might influence is thinking or what
subjects he takes or anything else to
comment well he certainly I mean it came
out of course during the course of his
yes he has a long history of being able
to use well his he was diagnosed I think
in his first year of research graduate
work Denis Sharma who was his supervisor
was told that he probably wouldn't live
the three years to do a PhD
well that was proved proved wrong but I
think Stephen was very visual also and
he's good on the analytic side but he
was good on on the visual side so
presumably earlier he was able to have a
sort of feeling for things in a tactile
sense as well but I think the visual
aspect of it wouldn't have been impaired
by his condition but later on he would
do work by getting a student and he
would tell the student what to put on
the board so that might be a diagram
sometimes or it might be a calculation
though survive
sir Gately sort of still does a visual I
mean yes the movement from the killer
sir that's right but the visual aspect
of it was it was certainly very
important in a lot of his thinking but
so I don't think that would have been
impaired by his condition but the
kinesthetic aspect yes I can see that
that must have been why don't we at this
point open up to the floor for questions
or comments and I think we we may have
some some microphones here so if you
have a question or a comment please come
down to the microphone
and we'll just start right here all
right can you hear me
okay and I was interested in the song
tags remarks and I sort of thought you
were going in a direction that you
didn't quite get to the you know when
you talk about these as celebrity
photographs I think the reason that
their celebrity photographs is because
they're so I think they're so compelling
and maybe that just makes me as naive as
John Q public but because and you
recognize all these too but as I was
watching them I was sort of saying WOW
and what I'm struck by really is the
potential for these folks the
photographs like these to lie basically
and to serve a primary propaganda
function so for instance if you look at
this what's remarkable about this
picture of the earth of the earth rising
is that when you look at this
you're something struck by the fact that
six billion of us most days see the moon
in the sky and none of us see it the
other way around and this picture here
shows us the opposite which is so out of
our experience and yet taken believe by
human beings that it's just has been a
tremendous shift in our perspective of
the universe and frankly I think it's a
one
at the NASA because you look at this and
you see my god no how can we not give
billions of dollars to those people so
we can change our view of the of the
universe this picture here Watson and
Crick it's not a photograph taken by
mrs. watts it's not a snapshot taken by
mrs. Watson it's really it's a marvelous
picture with a classic composition I
mean you talked about the framing of
these but it's really the composition of
this picture is what the photograph is
what makes it so remarkable it's very
classic in its you know and Crick is his
the movement of his body is mirroring
the movement of the double helix here
and what's really so and what's so
striking about this is everything ball
seeing probably pictures of Goddard
standing next to his rocket
well Goddard is all dressed up in a suit
everything is his tie is very neat
everything's in place and he looks
frankly like a nerd nobody's seen these
pictures from the 30s I think it was
recently another one the photo where is
this something very fetching about
Watson and Crick I think that's Watson
on the left I'm going to because we have
a lot of people started I mean if you
look at that picture of the fetus let's
take one over here I see this panel a
little bit as my daily life because
we've got the scientists on the right
and the writers on the left and I'm in
the center because my job for example
coming to science magazine was to turn
it from what I'm going to show you
tomorrow which some of you remember
which was a totally black and white had
almost no photos no illustrations to
something you recognize today which has
images now for the purpose that susan
worries about which
is to try to make our audience broader
when I came the audience was getting
older and and young people were used to
a colorful Newsweek in time kind of
universe and and and we knew that we
weren't going to have subscribers if we
stayed sort of like the New England
Journal of Medicine is with its cover as
you know when she says tables of
contents on the cover and so I we live
with this interesting battle in our
staff all the time how much space should
we give two images versus how much space
do we need for our words and I thought
it'd be just fun to tell one story for
the panel and see if it relates to this
sort of thinking that we have here I had
one time come to Newsweek and at one of
my first and most important lessons when
I started working at Newsweek was the
following it was right at the second
most lively period at the moment the
most lively period after Watergate when
the iran-contra events were taking place
and I learned what was what made a great
writer for a Newsweek or time by the
following I would meet people and then
some months after the first press
conference Reagan had you'll remember
some of you after many months when there
were no press conferences because he was
hiding worrying about what to say and I
would meet people and they'd say where
do you work and I'd say Newsweek and
they'd say oh you know I really loved
that story that you guys did where that
guy wrote that sentence Ronald Reagan is
a tall man but he looked small behind
the podium last night when he tried to
explain what was going on I call that a
word picture and the word picture has
the same function as the images when
they're working right which is to be
able to teach people a lesson in a very
quick way and I think the contrast
between that important kind of iconic
way of doing word pictures or image
pictures versus the kind of thing that
Susan Sontag probably is worrying about
like the sort of Mao image or even the
word image that is like Mao propaganda
that entire populations stop thinking
about what's behind them because that's
the image to me that's the interesting
debate that's going on there
panel and and that's what I wanted okay
thank you very much thank you
let's go here hi I think that the images
have been misclassified actually so the
bomb and the baby yes they're images I
think Watson and Crick are illustrating
a model and I also think that the human
evolution that that's also is creating a
model in other words those two images
are getting across ideas and then the
moon and the picture of the brain that's
actually data okay so those observations
we then infer results from right so I
don't I think you can too easily dismiss
all these images to smear the images
thank you can I just say something I'm
not trying to dismiss these images I'm
saying that there is a problem in
thinking that images really speak to us
I think it's more than we're speaking to
them that's what I'm saying of course
these are wonderful images one of my
most treasured book looks you know if I
had to sort of pair mine you know
inflated private library down to you
know a few hundred books I'm sure the
NASA I have a big big book of NASA
photographs of things seen from the moon
includes that image I adore that image
it's not that I don't think these are
great images most of them I just think
there's a problem in our using images
iconically
that they're not really telling us we're
telling them we're using them as as
platforms for associations and that we
have to understand always that images
are seen in a context I'm not saying
these aren't good images or beautiful
images or exciting images and I'm not
certainly saying that they are that
they're not famous for a reason they're
famous for reason because several of
them are absolutely wonderful the
question is what do they actually say do
they speak for themselves I think they
speak very little for themselves
including Greek and Watson I don't think
that's telling you anything that's
because we care about that
it wasn't the point of them so that just
indicate conversation well it is but
that's the conversation that it's
stimulated in me it's the conversation
that there's a problem about dealing
with very well-known images that we can
simply associate to as opposed to
[ __ ] that are more obscure or more
grouped I think grouped in the sense of
sequential hi Susan Susan Sontag I
enjoyed your comment that these
celebrity images are the visual
equivalent of sound bytes thanks for
thanks very much for that memorable
comment you you also said though that
you worried that we're not learning
anything from the images beyond what we
would get for reading narrative and text
and you also implied you at what you
asked whether images are actually
helping democratization and even
implying that there's some sort of
tyranny of an image and I want to give
you a different image a different
picture of how images aren't tyranny
when I read a scientific journal article
in my area of expertise I begin reading
the article and as soon as I've gotten
the main idea I stopped read stop
reading the text and I turn to it ever
non text material the author has given
me I turn to the tables the charts the
pictures perhaps the PET scans if it's a
neuroscience article and at that point
I'm not reading the text anymore and I'm
I'm reading the images and anyone else
do that and I think I'm doing it and I'd
like to get your reaction because I want
the pleasure and achievement of figuring
out the story for myself and coming to
my own interpretation thank you
I don't know what iiiii guess I don't
know really how to respond to that first
first I would never I never used the
word tyranny or any of those notions
that's very much not what I was saying
but I guess I'm not so interested in
figuring things out for myself I'm more
instant in learning so I wouldn't say
that I would abandon a text to look at
the image as as much as I am extremely
visual and spend a great deal of time
looking at images I mean Alan Lightman
picked me up at the airport and we went
to the museum and looked at images at
the Boston Museum you have a great
museum here I don't get to Boston more
than every two months or so and I go to
a museum I'm living a visual world I'm
visually besotted I'm just saying I
don't I think the question of what we
learn from images and what kinds of
images we learn from and the very many
different contexts that we look at
images in you know is a critical
question that's all I'm not talking
about images of tyrannize over us or
anything like that there's so many
different uses for images I suggest
waiting day what a being said is missing
the point if the a is to somehow conjoin
science and humanities the best of
science a better to humanity other word
what you've been describing is the kind
of phenomena you don't repeat it over
and over again without framework and
relevance in John and the question of
interests a question of interest is why
do we respond this way
why do certain images affect us a
certain way why does Framing occur to at
a certain degree why do we select a
certain complexity of image in art and
photography if we can't answer why then
we really under we don't understand the
human condition very well and I suggest
that where science and humanities are
likely to come together in this
particular subject is in fact through
neuroscience and through a
reconstructive human evolutionary has
been pieced together with the particular
areas of cultural history
and that then knowing how the brain is
constructed and programmed what our
sensory biases are how we develop these
capacities and biases and emotional
responses then we will have a truth
theory of saving art I noticed from the
audience we've been getting a lot more
comments than questions which is just
fine I believe that vision and language
and abstract thinking have common
origins in well the physiology of vision
and thinking and and language so the
process of getting meaning from image
through paying attention and parsing and
interpreting and ultimately changing our
internal state is substantially similar
to the process of understanding speech
act or understanding the disorder
process so could you comment them there
yeah I certainly think and I don't think
there's as I said earlier I don't think
there's a fundamental difference that
okay I mean a title of this meeting is
image and meaning and the question is
and the meaning is is is something which
is an internal if you like but it's it's
not so different from how one responds
to verbal or written words and again
it's there's something down there
there's some configuration of words on
the page and the meaning comes in in you
when you read that and it's similar with
an image I mean the image may convey
some meaning to you which isn't is it
isn't there in a sense abstractly in the
image is something which is how one
responds to the image all I'm saying is
I I think I'm agreeing with you if
that's what you were saying that that
there isn't the fundamental difference
between how one responds to a visual
image and how in response to words say
it's just different part of the brain
for example and
it has different characteristics
valuable in slightly different ways and
the meaning would be that we change the
distribution of propensities to do
things in the way meaning is one of
these very difficult things to come to
terms but I think it does require
consciousness I mean something can't
mean anything without your being aware
of it it seems to me I mean meaning is
is it that's why it's very difficult is
to you because it's things that we don't
know much about at the moment I mean my
experience comes largely from things
like mathematics where one can see that
it's fundamentally important what the
meaning is but I'm behind the set of
symbols I mean the you can't know
whether something something is right or
wrong if you like without knowing what
it means I'm just simply manipulating
the symbols isn't sufficient the meaning
that underlies those symbols is often
very important something you can
sometimes you can get away without the
meaning but ultimately you need to know
what these things mean and that must
apply also to visual images may convey
meaning
we saw awareness well I don't think so
no they can they can make you do things
or maybe or they can make you but I
don't think the meaning is there it's I
think that's a more a kind of automatic
response if they work I'm never quite
sure whether they do work but but if
they do it's as you say an unconscious
thing that's the whole point but it's
not really there's any meaning that gets
through to you it's it's that you may
feel you like something that you didn't
think you liked otherwise maybe that's
how it works
but I don't see any actual meaning
let's move to a question or comment over
yes thank you very much thank you my
name is Michael Charney I want to thank
the panel and for allowing the audience
to participate in this wonderful
dialogue I'd like to say that by the way
sight bite is a another way to talk
about a sound bite for the eye perhaps
it's be Yee in the current context in
any event looking at this I see an
ensemble the perhaps there are icons and
they're trivial or tri cliches but
actually there's a narrative here and in
looking at these images for me I try to
see what's in the mind of the person who
edited and selected them and arranged
them in a particular order what I see
here is seeing the unseen
and so image and meaning the image is
giving a meaning the meaning is what do
we see what we want to see here we see I
think my interpretation is a creation
myth as done perhaps for MIT it's rather
cold in its own way
but we see we start out with with energy
we actually perhaps God is up there in
the sky but there's this light and dark
a creation of light and dark the earth
is then separated we see the earth of
the water it's been created we then see
the beginning of life in the image of
the watson-crick a genome we then see
the product of that which is the
evolutionary stage of primates notice
that we're missing plants and other
general tax tax on taxonomic groups then
we see the the the neonate which is
recapitulating phylogeny I guess and
then we see consciousness and we see an
image of creation in the creative
thought which then closes the circle
because then we're back to the mind of
the creator thank you
I do think it takes quite a feat of
imagination to see that first image as
an image of energy and creation but
maybe I'm being too literal here looks
like an atom bomb to me but I'm just
being naive I guess that was a brilliant
run out was that was that the idea or
not it was not the conscious idea but
since we're talking about the
unconscious as well as the conscious who
knows I'll have a question here hi good
evening I was wondering if each of you
and if it's appropriate mr. Lightman you
as well comment on the distinction
between science communication and art as
concisely as possible if you can say I
do that eh I give that a try Alan let me
get that a try
science communication it's as you would
get in science and nature I'm trying to
be brief
it's all about objectivity repeatability
it is not about metaphor metaphor is not
welcome emotional expression is not
welcomed unless it's done very chastely
in the introduction of the discussion
the exact reverse of and it's about
repeatability the exact reverse is true
of art arc is designed to transmit
motion directly from the creator to the
to the audience and it is all about
light of 40 the gold the gold and silver
of science writing is the discovery of
something that is verifiably new in the
physical world the gold and silver of
art is the power and the originality of
the metaphor in the expression and the
impact the general nature of the impact
it has on the audience
I mean just make a brief comment and I
think they are different and the the
purpose of science journalism is is is
clarity I mean you want to get an idea
across as clearly as you can and you
might use a visual image to do this
whereas art isn't necessarily trying to
do that
but on the other hand I do think it's
it's is important that these images
should be pleasing and have an artistic
quality means you're more likely to want
to look at them and I think it's
important but it shouldn't detract from
the clarity I think the clarity is the
major thing that it's important that is
important in in in you know science
journalism at least the visual part of
it
clarity is important to both parts but I
mean we're talking about the visual
image whereas art doesn't necessarily
aim at the same thing but you know I
would like to see art also in such
images it's not the important thing
let's have a commenter question here I'd
like to make a comment on there the
Watson and Crick photo and this is a
very iconic image and it represents of
course one of the century's greatest
discoveries and yet and this has a
bearing on both this morning's session
on and on Susan Sontag comments I think
this photo is most interesting for what
it actually leaves out and that's the
fact that Watson and Crick based their
model in part on data which they took
from rosalind Franklin
and I think this this image was should
we see over and over again it really
it's only tells us half the story and I
wondered if people could comment on that
well we've got two images that rather of
obscure half the human race don't I
think it's very important absolutely
there are chronic images and an image
and images that tell us what we should
remember that's one of the things that
that's what I started to say then in my
remarks rather incoherently that images
tell us what we should remember and they
include or obscure things like cast them
into darkness and that's a perfect
example I'm very glad you made that
point thank you I'm sure we all bring
our own context to what we're seeing up
here and I have a brief comment and a
quick question and when I looked at the
images it seems to me that all of them
can cause us to reflect on a number of
different things but that brain scan I'm
not a neuroscientist but it may be the
state in which the mind is actually
meditative in reflection as but some
articles of that of late in some of the
magazines and journals when I see the
images together all of them except the
upper far left have to do with life or
evolution or reflecting on that
beautiful planet or that child or that
fetus all that reflective mind or
discovering life and DNA except the one
on the left I agree with you Susan to me
I see destruction so that was what a
quite a contrast I'm wondering if you
could share with us briefly if you had
to describe your image of what would
represent God is what would that visual
image be for each of you if we could
share that thank you
I actually drew a picture of the creator
in one of my books and Susan might be
interested in this because I gave a
lecture in which I shown this picture
and somebody at the end of the lecture
asks the question and said in your
depiction of God creating the universe
why did you depict her with a beard and
so I said well let's have that picture
back again and I pointed out that
actually there's deliberately two
different interpretations of that
picture one was it as a beard and the
other was the hair coming around like
this so so it was anyway it's I I should
say I'm not show an atheist an atheist
should really talk about this question
at all so somebody else maybe heaven I'm
afraid for the same reason Roger Penrose
just stated I would have to disqualify
myself
pash well we we have run out of time
tonight
but should we have a couple we'll have
two more comments or questions from the
audience from both sides here about her
experience last month in accepting the
Jerusalem prize in which she challenged
some of the popular images and meanings
that it go along with it in the
political arena I believe you were
quoted as saying I believe the doctrine
of collective responsibility is a
rationale for collective punishment is
never justified militarily or ethically
and I mean of course the
disproportionate use of firepower
against civilians the demolition of
their homes the destruction of their
orchards and grows the deprivation of
their livelihood and access to
employment to schooling medical services
or is the punishment for hostile
military activities in the vicinity of
those civilians and you are of course
referring to the Palestinians that I
congratulate you for making that
statement more or less than the jaws of
the lion and I wonder what sort of
reaction you've gotten for it and what
sort of visual images would make those
sentiments come home to
people in America that paid a lot of the
bills for those types of activities and
two people in Jerusalem way you spoke
well I only like to make a you know
political statements about things that I
know at firsthand IIIi don't think it's
appropriate I mean I thank you for your
support but I think we should stay with
the subject this evening maybe we can
talk about it out I do stand very much
for those sentiments I was very glad to
make that statement and I feel very
passionately about it but it's not the
subject tonight hi this isn't firm is
Santa ignores it about images this is a
this is a question for dr. Wilson I I
personally have always found myself kind
of not really knowing what I want to do
drifting around not without really a
sense of purpose but you you've taken
ants and you've made them your life and
I was wondering how you can how I could
never imagine taking something supposed
to so specific and indulging myself
completely in it and I was wondering
whether I mean how you think your life
is how by focusing on something so
specifically you think that do you think
that you have a broader I don't know
just your thoughts on it really
I
well I think the greatest advice
possibly the most effective advice I've
ever given the young scientist is to
find the subject in the great temple of
scientists the room and the bench and
the subject that you feel a surge of
passion of interest in and go for it
that's the best I can say how do I be
why did I become passionate pavan's yes
let me see let me suggest at the next
opportunity you put down some cookie
crumbs on the ground near an ant nest
and watch and start studying them and
you will see you see what comes as close
to what life must be like might be like
on another planet as you might hope ever
to see on this one
I'm going to all-out one more question
and then we have to end so now where the
question is coming from over here can
you ask have to comment our question
thank you I was wondering if the members
of the panel could comment about the
importance of images for the education
of the general the education of the
general public about science including
the notion that perhaps images could
contribute to the inspiration of the
public toward supporting great
scientific achievements such as a trip
to Mars or simply the importance of
images that serve to draw the public
into learning about the science about
the world around us most distinguished
and practiced ex-father tourism of just
the subject fair question I think that
images inspire us just as novels do and
you were really speaking about looking
to the future and and getting excitement
for the future and I believe that a
picture of Mars from from space that the
Mars pictures whatever that the
scientific enterprise is a picture of ed
Wilson's ants I think inspire us I know
that's a try phrase but it's it's true I
mean we've all reacted to these images
in a very visceral way and Susan pointed
out that that that those are some what
they're they're they're all pictures
that we've seen before and yet they
still have the
power to evoke a reaction to us as Roger
Penrose began speaking we could see that
that that he was emotionally affected by
these images and I think that that
images have that power and to the extent
that that that the scientific enterprise
is a human enterprise that our emotional
support is important and images have
that power so I will end there and let
me thank everyone for coming tonight
[Applause]